I've now switched coffee to my Wisconsin
JJ Watt mug just for this phone
conversation here on the Rich Eisen show
how are you Jonathan I'm doing well I
mean I'm doing fine but I wish you
didn't have this mug in front of me I'll
be very honest with you Johnson I'll be
very honest with you being a Michigan
grad you Chris Brockman you want to read
to Jonathan Taylor what JJ Watt is
inscribed on the mug beneath the final
score of theirs the score 35 14 and then
at the bottom of it it says this cub
holds Rich Eisen steers that's right
there you go now have you met JJ what
Jonathan I have not had the chance to
meet JJ why yes possible so JJ you have
you not even texted spoken to to JJ Watt
Jonathan Taylor I haven't got a chance
to connect with him yeah I mean he has a
lot going on you know outside of
football too now just literally no I
can't believe like do I need to hook
does a Michigan guy need to hook to
Wisconsin studs up do I need to do that
I mean that would be an honor and it
would be a pleasure oh wow okay
Jonathan what has life been like for you
the last few weeks with a spotlight
being thrown on you with your play
what's it been like for you it's been
really fun and especially you know with
the defense playing the way that they
are I finally get to talk about you know
someone other than myself I get to talk
about and brag about our defense those
guys are playing lights-out and I just I
can't say you know how proud I am of
them be just because the situation's we
put them in sometimes and they bail us
out so they're playing late so how does
it get from New Jersey get to Wisconsin
Jonathan's really hard work and
dedication were one of the biggest
things is you know of course you know
there there's a pipeline from Jersey
Madison and you know you just come to
something that kind of draws you in here
I don't know just being a running back
I'm from Jersey it kind of draws you in
but once you get here and you put
yourself in a position and you take
football out of your equation you can
see yourself here in Madison living as a
regular person like a non-athlete so I
think that's just one of the biggest
things it's just
the people here where is that pipeline
is it under the turnpike I never saw em
from Staten Island I never saw that
pipeline the pipeline is an invisible
pipeline and only Jersey guys could see
the pipeline this is who else has been
in that pipeline for those who may not
know Jonathan you know like Ron Dayne
Anthony Davis like some some of those
guys those guys are our big name guys
who really carried the torch here and
that's just like from my position but
those are some of the guys who carried
the torch here and one of the biggest
things is you just want to do the same
thing and you want to uphold that
standard what makes you so dynamic do
you think Jonathan what-what-what is in
you and your DNA that makes you perfect
for this position at this school at this
time yeah I think being at this school
at this position the thing that makes me
so dynamic is my my competitiveness the
willingness to try and get better
because if you look at the backs we've
been here I mean there have been some
great back so being at the position here
you can't be complacent you know if you
want to try to raise the bar and you
want to try to make it tougher for the
next group of running backs again and
you're gonna have to compete every
single day with yourself in order to try
and get better to do so so who's your
guy growing up that you're like okay
this makes me want to be a running back
so my favorite running back growing up
and the NFL was Arian Foster that was
one of my favorite guys hence the reason
I got 23 and then of course soon to be
you know Melvin Gordon it's just an
extremely talented bat so those two guys
the Melvin Gordon was my college guy and
then Arian Foster was my NFL guy does
Arian Foster know that you were 23 for
him does he know that I'm pretty sure I
don't know if you've seen anything yet
on me saying that but I've said it off
multiple times so I don't know if he's
seen him there not yet do you know him -
you need to be fixed up with him - cuz
that you can fix me up with that well
you know who couldn't do that Jonathan
is JJ Watt cuz you know Arian Foster's a
former Texan so let me help you with
both how about that I would appreciate
that so much this is amazing this is
amazing and it's so funny I never
thought I had this in me because when
you were running for 200 yards against
Michigan and a half a day I was so
pissed off
I was so upset but every I this is the
first time I think you and I have ever
spoken I've heard nothing but great
things about you and who you are was
made you the person that you are
Jonathan Taylor really I think you know
just humble beginnings growing up back
to Salem New Jersey was my mother and
father they just instilled in me hard
work I mean nothing nothing too flashy
nothing too extravagant or deep story
but just understanding that they want to
work every single day understanding that
things had to be done so when I'm here
that's just kind of the mentality that I
have and as far as growing up the same
mentality to just things have to be done
and you know you're gonna have to put
your best foot forward and you have to
do what you can to get things done okay
so I'm gonna ask you a couple of
questions here it's the same it's the
same sentence but I'm gonna change the
the last word well I see you in
Indianapolis in December that's the goal
okay well I see you in Indianapolis in
February bad okay so next February I see
you in Indianapolis Jonathan now that
was that would be the goal that would be
if everything plans out well and you
know you can't look too far ahead but
you know of course everyone at this
level would love to be there in February
mm-hmm so this is your last year in
Wisconsin you never know you never know
what can happen that's why we got to
take it day by day game by a game and
see where things lie in the year there
you go you're so smart see but here's
the thing - Jonathan I'm trying to get
you out of the big ten I'm trying to get
you out of the big ten as fast as I can
see cuz again you know next level it
does appear that you have the skillset
to succeed at the next level who's the
current guy in the NFL right now that
you look like you think you you have the
same skillset as someone in the NFL
right now Jonathan oh really
everyone's really different but I could
say some guys that I like to try and
model my game after just because of the
way they run and I like the way today
they play the game
definitely todd gurley you know he's
very versatile but he is a great runner
man Hazuki Elliot those are two guys who
I think are you know and bigger guys
it's like not similar build but you know
kind of a workhorse guy but it's also
very versatile so I think those are two
guys who are in the game right now that
I really like to try a lot of my game
after so let me let me also follow up
with a similar question here will I see
you in New York City in December as
every day if everything goes well we
keep on winning that'll be a be another
possibility as well so what would you do
if you won the heisman trophy Jonathan
Taylor what would you what would that
mean to you oh it would mean a lot and
as far as what I would do the only thing
that you can do is thank everyone who
helped you along the way to get to that
point teammates coaches you know just
parents you know everyone who's helped
you to get to that point where you are
as a man and as a player the only thing
you could do is thank them okay so this
week against Illinois are you aware of
the milestone that you have in front of
you this week first yeah yeah they told
me about it at the end of last game for
rushing yards shy of 5,000 in your
career becoming the fourth player to
reach that mark by the end of your
junior season the others are LaMichael
James Ron Dayne we have mentioned in
Herschel Walker that's a pretty
respectable neighborhood sir and then
and then I I don't know if you're ready
for me to root for you Jonathan
um but week 9 you're playing Ohio State
Jonathan and my children know to root
for two teams Michigan in anybody
playing Ohio State that day would be you
sir so you go okay thank you you are
very welcome and I appreciate you
joining this program Jonathan this has
been a pleasure getting to meet you so
let's go through our checklist here okay
okay all right checklist number one
hooking you up with JJ Watt correct okay
checklist number two hooking you up with
Arian Foster yes okay that's number two
number three is getting you out of the
big ten immediately if not sooner
you know what I've seen enough for you
and I call the combine I do the combine
for NFL Network and I would love to meet
you there if not as soon as you would
like how does that sound sound good okay
and I'm drinking out of this Cup right
now it does not hold my tears but they
you know it's it's a great photograph of
Beijing on it
Congrats on where everything going on
for you Jonathan we'll chat soon very
much
you got it thanks for joining well I
appreciate the time you bet anytime
anytime that's Jonathan Taylor at JT 23
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on VR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app